hey what's up guys and welcome to
something a little different as you can
probably tell this is Dark Souls modded
and it's going to be the first in a
three-part series where I'm going to mod
the game in some of my favorite ways and
basically showcase it to you so it's
pretty obvious what I've modded in this
video we're playing in first-person and
you're watching me fight through the
first stage in order to reach the taurus
demon and playing like this was actually
a lot of fun obviously it's not perfect
there are some camera bugs but it's
definitely functional as you'll see I
don't have too much trouble making my
way through the stage one of the best
things I've actually done is pick up
this spear and this was a good choice
for a few reasons
one it's highly visible in first-person
and two rolling actually messes with the
camera so you tend to use your shield a
lot and in any situation where you use
your shield the spear is just naturally
a good choice so what's it like playing
in first-person well you'll get some
idea as you watch these gameplay clips
but if I had to describe it to someone
else basically it's like Skyrim but with
gameplay the combat works surprisingly
well but I'd only really recommend it to
an experienced player who knows weapon
movesets
enemy patterns and someone who has a
really good grasp of the controls and
the reason I say this is that it's not
perfect the camera has trouble adjusting
sometimes and if you know exactly how to
move your character in the game then
you'll have a much better time but
generally this works well enough that I
reckon you could do a really good
playthrough with it I really like it the
most important thing by far is that it
actually puts you in the shoes of your
character
so Dark Souls is a tense game but when
you're actually looking around from a
first-person perspective it becomes that
bit more tense
for example there's something more fun
about turning around and seeing an enemy
right in your sights with the sword
raised or when you see an arrow flying
towards a character playing with this
limited view just means that you're more
surprised by things and it makes the
action a bit more visceral I guess you
feel as though you're playing as the
character much more and I guess playing
as the character extends to all
first-person games I mean this affects
more than just the combat Dark Souls is
a game where you really experience the
world around you and I think that
meeting NPCs and experiencing the world
around you fits so well with the souls
game and I definitely wouldn't mind from
developing a first
an RPG similar to this remember that
some of the first games from made were
Kingsfield games and those were in first
person imagine a modern day kings filled
with souls gameplay and that would be so
good so many people will click this
video intending to figure out exactly
how I made my game in first-person but
unfortunately the person who told me
doesn't want this information available
to the public the program I'm using can
be used for many more malicious things
and I don't really want to be
responsible for the PC version
decreasing in quality at the same time I
also think some of you deserve to know
having the ability to mod the game in
this way opens up so much creative
potential it's the reason why recent
videos have such great footage I can
move the camera around I can make people
invisible I can summon other people into
my world without being white phantoms
all of this is great and there are some
of you out there who would be able to
make some really good content with these
tools however there are also people out
there who would invade other people's
worlds and mess with their games so
maybe it's for the best if I keep this
information to myself even if a big part
of me thinks that it's not a big deal if
everyone knows let me know what you
think I'm really torn on this issue
anyway I mentioned before that my recent
videos have increased in quality I was
looking at my older videos the other day
and I don't know why they got so many
views my microphone was terrible my
narration was really melodramatic and I
didn't have nearly the same amount of
skill in gathering footage I'm speaking
mostly about my first few prepare to cry
videos with the prepare to cry series I
focused on the best stories first like
Artorias siegmeyer the sisters of chaos
those were the three most emotional
stories in the game so naturally I did
them first the problem with that is that
now that my video quality has improved
the three best stories were done when I
just wasn't really experienced so I
think I'll redo those videos I won't
delete them but I'll remake them with
new footage better narration and just
better overall quality would you guys
like that let me know so that pretty
much does it for this video the rest of
the video is just me trying to take out
the Taurus demon if you want to see how
that ends feel free to stick around but
um if you haven't subscribed already
feel free to subscribe at the next few
videos I'm going to be putting out are
also mod videos showcasing two more mods
that I actually think are better than
this mod if you can believe it
so as usual guys thanks for watching and
I'll see you guys next time